[Music]
urban code deploy from IBM is an
application deployment automation
platform that combines robust visibility
traceability and auditing capabilities
into one optimized package urbancode
deploy separates itself from other
deployment automation platforms by
allowing me to handle deployment to
distributed data centers clouds and
virtualized environments with
easy-to-use process orchestration
through one dashboard you can promote
consistently and seamlessly across
environments scaling up to enterprise
class deployments with thousands of
servers designed elements can be
templated allowing for easy reuse across
massive environments with versioning and
rollbacks
enabled anywhere in the process advanced
collaboration is enabled by a robust
inventory management system that lets
users know what's already been deployed
to an environment and what still needs
to be deployed with snapshots urbancode
keeps a concise bill of materials that
reduces risk by tracking any collection
of application components that are
deployed together code station is urban
codes built in artifact repository that
helps guarantee what was built by
development is exactly what's deployed
to your environment bit for bit this way
what is tested together can be released
together ensuring you can develop and
deploy with confidence urban code deploy
also empowers development teams to be
self-sufficient by enabling the
on-demand deployment of individual
components and full application
deployments promotion of these
applications can be controlled with
approvals and environment gates ensuring
compliance and quality from development
to production with an unprecedented
portfolio of benefits and capabilities
urbancode deploy represents an
industry-leading application release
automation platform that enables
enterprises to seamlessly deliver
applications through their network to
the cloud and to the
see how urbancode deploy can evolve your
deployment process